occurrence world tour ce prix en
particulier à deux films récompensés ont
laissé la seule fois où on a la
possibilité de voir primer deux films où
il fonda also donc nous avons considéré
il fallait récompenser ces deux films
pour se précise le prix du jury
les misérables là
pakula haut pour kléber mendoça vélo à
ioulia normal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wall street
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va se jouer au point
est ce qu'on a on a un seul on a un seul
objet mon dieu
wahou bah merci merci merci l'asie
alors je vais commencer par remercier
thierry frémaux merci à thierry d'avoir
une audace de choisir ce film dans la
compet officielle à mort merci beaucoup
je suis très content très ému merci aux
membres du jury
merci beaucoup d'avoir cru en france
film vincent maraval jean labadie une
sacrée équipe merci les gars mais
producteurs bien sûr je demandais de
devenir si c'est important d'être là à
mes côtés du cai a dit christophe barral
[Applaudissements]
alors déjà merci aux comédiens ici
présents à alexis valenti damien bonnart
du brigand gars bravo les gars juliette
ou par non l'extraordinaire merci pour
ton image à flora veulent clairement
montueux ce qui est extraordinaire et
sans doute la meilleure montée au monde
je suis très content de bosser avec l
avant macri courtage mais ici présentes
kim chapiron romain gavras
on le dit simon kjaer oxmo puccino elle
sa 4l et tout le monde parce qu'on est
au niveau toumani sangaré chef du
village de gare à l'eau merci les gars
dans cette aventure ont fermé les
bosquets je voulais pas d'où je viens
c'est important c'est important
voilà
j'ai juste dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est
possible on part de rien on n'a pas fait
d'école de cinéma ça fait 20 ans qu'on
se bat et finalement aujourd'hui on se
retrouve là un competo fille ciel ségo
merci merci à ma famille je vais pas
citer tous les noms parce qu on est
beaucoup à la famille dit ça et ça roule
à bonn mon frère tu ma famille ma mère
mes enfants habib el-adli à la salle je
vous aime très fort à ma femme et je
suis heureux vraiment je suis vraiment
heureux merci à toutes les personnes qui
ont travaillé sur ces festivals et
edouard weil assure bravo il doit
remercier ces coups-là et justin le
dernier mot mon film des misérables
parle
les rapports entre différentes
communautés dans ce territoire est en
fait le seul ennemi en commun qu'ils ont
je sais c'est la misère enfin le sel est
venu en commun qui entre ses habitants
et les policiers c'est la misère donc je
veux dédier ce prix à tous les musées de
france et d'ailleurs
merci
mais je prétends deux mondes ouverts
donnerait si ces peines beaucourt
braziou je les en remercie les membres
du jury le président ça fait maintenant
20 ans que je viens au festival de
cannes c'est ma vingtième année et tout
au début j'étais un journaliste de
cinéma j'étais un critique de cinéma et
j'ai découvert de nombreux films ici
dans la salle lumière mais également
dans la salle debussy et la quinzaine
des réalisateurs la semaine de la
critique
donc ça m'a un petit peu sa ferme de me
retrouver maintenant ici de l'autre côté
du public et recevoir ce prix du jury
dans un dans une complication aussi
magnifique merci beaucoup à tout en
restant disponible sous forme de
parabole du casino genre laisseront un
village maintenant on rêve tous adresse
g13 et remercie bien sûr les membres du
jury un peu paumé je me tourne vers le
public brésilien et je vais dire deux
mots en portugais 10e qui marque la fin
fumée qui vaut vais au travail de
montage est certes les barjots d'âge de
blasio est atteint l'effort de blasio et
à ce jeu pesos à l'australian le paquet
scientifique à 6,30 urgent et des
attaques et incendies en rade
la seule manière et à choquer ou
dédicacerai mes bras tandis très mal
dosé très belle adresse du brasier la
science l'éducation et la culture
village de semaine extraordinaire au
brésil notre film emporté également un
prix un certain regard et maintenant ce
prix ici nous sommes des ambassadeurs de
la culture nous travaillons pour la
culture au brésil ce dont nous avons
besoin c'est de votre soutien et de
votre version hybride de gens bizarres